so if I see the team having
interpersonal conflict or issues I'll
usually talk to each of the two people
individually first to get you know her
side his side and then I'll usually chew
on it first so I can kind of walk around
in both of their shoes and then usually
I'll get agreement on both of those like
do you think it'd be better if we talked
about this you know together but my
first intention is I will give them the
words that I think they should use with
one another without me in the room if
they can't resolve it that way then I
think we would come in as third party
mediator and then usually it has to be
more like a papa talk of like Big
Picture This is where we're trying to go
these are the values that the company
stands for where are we having conflict
here what is the problem that we need to
solve the very worst case scenario is
these are the conditions under which you
guys need to work together if Johnny
gives you the materials in this way Sam
is that acceptable to you yes Johnny if
Sam interacts with you in this way and
he says it this way are you good with
that yes if they both adhere to those
principles trust ends up getting rebuilt
and then mutual respect and like we
don't need everybody to like one another
but we need everyone to respect one
another